foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream extreme Edition we are
working as we have in the past without
Annette who once again did not show up
for work today yeah we fired her we
talked about this she still didn't show
up for work okay now what I realized
about Annette is that actually I've
never even met her I don't think she's
ever showed up for work and I drove by
you keep different hours I drove by the
place that we send her checks it's a
bowling alley so I don't know what's up
but worse than that however we are
working without Zach yes now Zach is I
probably shouldn't say this widely so
let's keep it between us and our
audience Zach is on the lamp
he is uh on the run from the Marshall
service and he is in pick a continent
he's on the other side of the Equator at
the moment pick a continent any
continent yes Antarctica okay he is at
the brown station in Antarctica and I'm
sure the Marshall service will uh be
able to find him there it's not a highly
populated place he shouldn't be hard to
spot even if he's uh in Disguise so
anyway
um Zach is uh
not present behind the producer's desk
which means I'm doing a few extra things
that I don't usually have to do and I
partially understand so anyway it's all
good we'll see how it goes though indeed
yeah we will and uh this is a new it's
an unusual week for a lot of reasons uh
we are also not doing a q a today so
it's going to be this we're going to try
to keep it tight and uh and and just
constrained and just like that I should
point out I am Dr Brett Weinstein which
I forgot to mention you are Dr Heather
Hein which they mostly know but some may
not some may not and this is live stream
number are we still in the it's a one
it's called a live stream
yeah it's a line actually I mean if you
got to pick a flavor for a stream lime
isn't that totally yeah I'm stream uh
164 I believe 164 164. uh so we are
going to talk a little bit about sort of
um let's see the nature of science race
death
sex
all of those things today a little bit
different a little bit philosophical
yeah yeah usually when people talk about
uh Sex and Death it's in the other order
but I guess but I think this is the
order in which we're going to take it
today I think I I believe it is wise for
us to separate ourselves from those
other conversations in any case so yeah
all right this is all good now I have to
remember some more things
just yet okay no you uh you get cooking
and I will prepare over here you won't
even notice I'm doing no excuse me I
won't
um
we are grateful to you our audience
always uh and I am grateful to the um
remarkable number of new subscribers to
Natural Selections this week that was uh
prompted part I Believe by sub stack
thank you uh making Natural Selections
their number one featured
um newsletter for a spell this week for
a few days early in the week by the way
hell yeah and congratulations hell yeah
that was great uh and uh and then the
piece that I posted on Tuesday called
apparently we're the Bad Guys
basically attempted
um you know I I was not attempting to be
thorough I knew that I was not being
thorough I would love for someone else
to to be thorough but I just you know
it's getting really old it's getting
really old that people continue to tell
us that we are the ones who are you know
killing people and making errors across
the board and I said you know
things that we said throughout the uh
throughout the spell that we've been
doing this and um and you know we got
some things wrong here are a couple
things we got wrong here's a hell of a
lot of things we got right and I linked
I don't know maybe a tenth of what I
could have linked and just ran out of
time but people have really liked that
piece and I encourage you to go and
check it out if you have not share it
like it subscribe there subscribe here
on our um on Brett Weinstein's YouTube
channel which is the main one that we're
streaming from also on Odyssey and the
clips Channel too where you can find a
briefer briefer things that we talk
about right like subscribe comment in
the comments we actually want to know
why it is unlikely that Annette lives in
a bowling alley so if you feel like
you're telling it okay yeah absolutely
we do yeah we talked about this yeah I
mean it wasn't even like a you know
there was a second story where she might
be renting an apartment there's just
nothing it's a bowling alley seller
uh we can't we could fire her nope nope
nope nope nope basement
oh seller guys right okay I I'm on track
yes all right uh so you could also uh
consider joining one of our patreons uh
next week before the live stream you
will be having one of your patreon
conversations uh we have private monthly
q and A's at mine and you can also
access our Discord community of either
of our patreons where uh people are
having honest conversations on all sorts
of topics
um through many different media and it's
really it's really quite wonderful you
can even have an honest conversation
about dishonest conversations and then
you will you will have your pick there
are so many that you could choose from
Yes
um I sure
okay now you're about to be up we also
are supported by our sponsors who we
carefully uh pick and curate and we only
read ads for sponsors that we actually
approve of and really vouch for so here
we go all right we are about to
transition into ad mode here it is Boom
okay there it is ADD mode our first
sponsor this week has become a favorite
here at Dark Horse it's House of
macadamias that's right nuts macadamia
nuts tree nuts are delicious and
nutritious they're generally high in fat
low in carbs which is increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you unlike what you've been being
told by you know the food pyramid people
forever but each species of nut is
different and for many of us macadamias
are the best macadamia nuts take a very
long time to grow
and because they're both rare and highly
sought after they have both the dubious
distinction of being the world's most
expensive nut and
um both I just read both there for no
good reason they have the dubious
distinction of being the world's most
expensive nut
between the taste and the health
benefits though they're worth it they
have fewer carbohydrates than most other
nuts for instance half of what cashews
or pistachios have and two-thirds of
what almonds have which makes them the
perfect snack for breaking a daily fast
and controlling blood glucose they're
also uniquely rich in omega-7s including
especially palmettoic acid and
unsaturated fat that has been linked to
Natural collagen production fat loss and
heart health
and House of macadamias is intent on
making this amazing food accessible to
everyone they've partnered with more
than 90 farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks these include their dark
chocolate dip academias and a delicious
assortment of bars made with 45
macadamia nuts in flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut but
our favorites of all of their products
and we've had almost all of them I think
are the Simply Delicious salted
macadamias made with namibian sea salt
just macadamia nuts namibian sea salt
amazing they're really great we love
them and think that you will too they
come in these little bags that are easy
to carry around and you know when you
when you feel like noshing they're a
great a great thing to eat our house of
academias Highly recommends House of
macadamias for all of your macadamic
needs looking for something nourish and
energize you while you pursue while you
um
well in pursuit of the truth right in
English yeah or the next Summit that's
it okay
seriously if you want to climb a
mountain or uh or think through hard
ideas you're going to need some good
nourishing food and how some macadamias
has just the stuff for you go to
www.houseofmacademias.com and use code
Darkhorse for a 20 discount on every
order plus star course listeners will
receive a complimentary four ounce bag
of macadamias when they order three or
more boxes of any Macadamia product
once again that's www.house of
macadamias
m-a-c-a-d-a-m-i-a-s use code Darkhorse
for 20 off every order you won't be
sorry
before you read the second ad I am as
you read just gonna go off screen for a
moment and advise our other son that we
can hear him all right okay I bet you
can't guess who our next ad though is if
you if you do guess I will buy you
dinner okay oh awesome well we seem to
have a a a a nut theme going so maybe
it's like a nuts or seeds or something
seed very good all right all right fair
and square
all right uh I was excited to read this
one this week
um because after covet who knows whether
they're related but um I had some gut
distress and as all of you know uh gut
biota are
um very very important to all sorts of
aspects of Health for reasons that we
are only beginning to fully understand
but in any case our next sponsor is seed
seed is a company focused on bacteria
and the microbiome they make a probiotic
called ds01 daily uh symbiotic here at
Darkhorse we always prefer eating real
food to taking pills but we really love
this product if you've tried probiotics
before and they haven't worked or you've
wondered about them and haven't ventured
in this is a different kind of probiotic
and it's fantastic
there are a lot of things that you can
do to enhance your health our sign off
here at Darkhorse includes three of them
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside but a lot is hidden
in those words what const words there's
more than one word in that it's it's all
it's almost Beyond a phrase
what constitutes good food for instance
good food is real food food whole food
food that has been alive recently and
was grown with care and conditions as
ancient as possible given the
constraints of the 21st century but even
many people who eat such a diet are
missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which may harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them
this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient dense food and
avoid processed foods and sugar but not
all probiotics are created equal seed
ds01 daily symbiotic is a broad spectrum
two in one probiotic plus Prebiotic it
contains 24 distinct probiotic strains
and they are in a two in one capsule
which protects the probiotic until they
hit the colon where they are most
effective if you have taken a probiotic
before and never felt a difference it's
likely because the good bacteria weren't
surviving your GI tract which is of
course built to kill off things that try
to get in through what you eat with a
very low ph
and that's why you've likely never felt
a difference
um seed is designed differently that's
why it works it's designed to protect
the important stuff so it passes through
that very acidic environment and gets to
the place where you actually need them
Deeds daily symbiotic it's one of these
obvious in retrospect yeah
things right like oh you're going to
have to double haul that in order to get
it through the part of the digestive
tract which is designed to destroy
things that come through it's the built
to get through that first line of
defense because these are um good things
that you need seeds daily symbiotic
supports gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis we have heard
from several people who have used seed
and Report improvements to their
digestive function in just 24 to 48
hours start a new healthy habit today
visit seed.com Darkhorse and use the
code Darkhorse to redeem 20 off your
first first months of seeds DS1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com slash
Darkhorse and use the code Darkhorse at
checkout and yes I did experience a
difference always hard to know whether I
was just moving that direction or not
but it felt likely to have been
responsive to this probiotic yeah it's
it's great stuff
all right and our final sponsor this
week is mud water uh and before I start
eating I'm going to just show the the
can and I will say that all of our
sponsors this week actually have great
packaging and that's in some way trivial
um but but it's nice right it's it's
nice to feel like this the seed comes in
these nice glass jars and then they send
you the replenishment in um like
biodegradable bags uh and this is a nice
tin and the macadamia nuts come in these
nice little pouches um so I will advise
though yes
um from personal experience when you use
the mud water take it out of the tin
yeah so if you uh if you just put this
tin directly into your mug of hot water
you're not going to get the taste
sensation you're looking for and you're
also likely to chip your teeth so but it
will last longer but it's a trade-off it
is a trade-off although you will be
heating the contents in the tin by uh
submerging it it will last less Long
than if you don't do it but a lot longer
than if you use the product then if you
actually use the product yeah all right
I think we've now thoroughly confused
the matter yes I recommend actually
using mud water it's fantastic
um
it's a coffee alternative
um but I think that's that's sort of
what we're told to say it's a coffee
alternative but really it's a delicious
it's a delicious drink I mean you can
add it to lots of stuff as we'll talk
about here
um but it's a delicious drink that you
for the morning with a little bit of
caffeine about a 70 amount of coffee uh
but you know if you have a tendency to
want to drink warm drinks during the day
and sometimes it's coffee sometimes it's
tea put this into your rotation it's
really fantastic it's made with four
medicinal mushrooms plus herbs and
spices spices with seventh the caffeine
is a cup of coffee you'll get energy
without the anxiety Jitters or crash of
coffee if that sort of thing happens to
you
and it's delicious if you like the
routine of making and drinking a cup of
forms in the morning but don't drink
coffee or trying to cut down try this
Blood water maybe you resolve to drink
less coffee in the new year or are
realizing at the end of February nope
beginning of March but it's not quite
working
if you're looking for a different way to
kick off your day a delicious warming
enhancing way that isn't just a caffeine
Rush try mud water each ingredient was
added with intention it has cacao and
chai Masala chai with black tree black
tea ginger cardamom cloves nutmeg black
pepper cacao lion's mane cordyceps Saga
and reishi cinnamon turmeric Himalayan
salt it's really excellent and they also
make a non-dairy creamer which comes in
this little bag I was going to say fancy
it's like the opposite of fancy which is
nice you don't want a fancy bag to have
your creamer it's made of coconut milk
and MCT and it's it's great and they
also make a sweetener out of coconut
palm sugar wait a minute
do I have the no I have the creamer here
yep a sweetener out of coconut palm
sugar and lucuma which is the fruit of
an Andean tree used by the Inca to add
if you prefer those options I don't know
how much the ink I use glaucoma anymore
but it was used by the
in the subjugation of their neighbors
which wasn't as bad as it might have
been
really yeah
No actually that's where we're going
perhaps we should have that conversation
later but there was a kind of a
federating effect uh well so okay let's
let's let's go through here and let's
actually start the top of the hour by
with a brief discussion with the Inca
okay sure rather than adding that into
the middle of the mud water add all
right
um
or you can mix and match add a bit of
their coconut milk and MCT creamer with
some honey from your favorite bees and
if you don't have favorite bees get some
honey from your favorite beekeeper as
we've talked about before find a
favorite beekeeper if you don't have one
uh or use their lacuma and coconut palm
sugar sweetener and skip the bees
entirely we've been known to add mud
Waters coconut milk and MCT creamer into
their hot drinks as well and it's
delicious
mud Waters flavor is warm and spicy with
a hint of chocolate
um Ginger cardamom that my cloves as
I've already gone through it's also
delicious blended into a smoothie this
is not in the northern hemisphere not
really the Smoothie season but try it
with banana and Ice milk or milk like
substance mint and cacao nibs at any
point that the mint is growing outside
where you live is probably a good moment
for this smoothie and it's fantastic mud
water is 100 USDA organic non-GMO
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
and it allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash so visit mudwater.com
Darkhorse to support the show and use
code Dark Horse Mud at checkout for 15
off that's mud wtr.com Darkhorse use
darkhorsemud at checkout for 15 off
all right do it boom you did it all
right we are back in regular Dark Horse
mode all right so dark horse A La Mode
we're gonna call it are we and yet you
haven't brought me any ice cream no I
should have thought of that but anyway
perhaps next week
it won't happen
I know this probably true ice cream on
camera it would melt oh but it would
attract the cats where are the cats
where are they yeah don't know yeah
anyway
um should we start with a brief
discussion of uh of the Inca yes a brief
discussion for which I have not properly
prepared but I will say that the Incan
Empire was
a true Empire that stretched over
many hundreds of miles at least
many hundreds of miles I'm tempted to
think it might have been a thousand but
um in any case
linear down to the coast not so much
they didn't drop over into the Amazon
basin so much
a lot of the Andes yeah but in any case
what they did was they uh
they subjugated many a people but in the
subjugating of those people they also
linked them into a vast Trade Network
and they also brought with them a
a kind of wisdom about how to
um provide for the people who were
linked together in this large laborative
entity including
um the creation of these larders which
were basically excess food was stored in
a stable way for uh times of famine so
the point was if you were conquered by
the Inca you became part of this thing
that had actually a degree of uh at
least robustness if not anti-fragility
to it so anyway I I think you know you
and I have said uh that in some sense
the Maya were very much the like the
Greeks of the new world and the Inca
were like the Romans but in both cases
there were substantial differences and
the um the nature of the Empire that the
Inca had I'm not saying it didn't have
degrees of brutality obviously people
don't you know get conquered by Empires
easily but uh it deserves a fresh look
because it wasn't simply a new world
version of the Romans it was a very
different kind of Empire well I mean I
think
no Empire is simply
almost no long-standing Empire is simply
brutal and evil right so
um I don't we did not prepare this at
all there's just a line in the ad read
that we just did about about lucuma
um this this uh this tree this fruit
from this tree that the Inca apparently
used and I guess what what I can pull up
from memory since we didn't did not
think that we could be talking about the
Inca today
two of the cultures uh whom who who were
either incorporated into or ended up
sharing space with the Inca uh who
before the Spanish arrived with whom we
had some
you know interaction much later on right
in terms of what kinds of traces they
left are first the yumbo uh who uh who's
whose foot trails in
um you know in a particular amazing
um spot that we've spent time with
students in Ecuador
um the name of which I've now briefly
blanked on wait it starts with an
makuna yes
um so makapakuna which is a giant
Reserve very close to Quito has in it
these ancient yumbo trails and you know
this is this is volcanic soil but also
sort of a little bit clay e but you know
very very extraordinarily rich soil that
also when you walk a trail over and over
and over again the trail does not unlike
in the jungle unlike in the lowland
jungle to either side of the west or the
East is not going to disappear over time
it will basically just deepen and deepen
into deepen and so you can literally
walk and I actually I read a piece about
this that I can link to in the footsteps
of the umbo who were walking these
Trails hundreds of years ago and you
know that you are walking in their
footsteps because these are very narrow
paths that in some cases are are so worn
in that the sides of the trails are four
or five even six feet on either side of
you oh higher than that they can be and
often they're they're not very high at
all but these these trails are ancient
they are absolutely ancient and they're
obviously so in Ecuador the Inca weren't
present for very long it was something
like 80 years before the the Spanish
showed up so to some degree because
we've spent time in Ecuador and we
haven't spent time in Peru or Bolivia
our understanding of the Incan influence
is kind of a Kinder gentler if you will
because it just didn't have that much
time before you know the next the next
Empire came and and slaughtered them
so um the yumbo were as we came to
understand being at makapakuna
effectively employed not enslaved but
employed as
um as Trail Runners to deliver messages
and to some degree I think goods between
uh distant places
um by the Inca and in the kanyari they
were ironically the Amazon of their day
they were way too high for that to be
the kids they were the headwaters of the
Amazon is the way to think of them I
guess that's right and so it's too far
north to be probably near the headwaters
of the Amazon and also just over on the
western side rather than the Eastern
side but yeah now the the theme I think
the pun was worthwhile it was in the
ballpark enough enough to be justified
okay which few puns are this is true on
this in this point you and I will agree
and then for a little farther south in
Ecuador you have Inga parka which is the
largest Inc it's called an Incan uh ruin
in Ecuador but in fact what it is is a
shared ruin of uh the result of a royal
wedding between and I don't remember
which sex is which but let's call it
like an Incan
um prince and a kanyari princess or
maybe it was the other Sexes but uh the
Inca came in tried to
um tried to conquer the kanyari the
canary were having none of it and they
actually were able to resist and the
Inca did what sometimes will happen in
such a case they sort of said okay well
never mind then how about we join forces
and so you end up with uh you ended up
with not just Inca Perka which was a
center of culture uh but it was it was a
it was a hub for many for many places
including you know maybe yumbo Trail
Runners but also down to the coast uh
where there were additional like the
valdivians and such they were doing
trade uh with the Valdivia so the Inca
were hardly the only people uh in
pre-columbian Andean uh Andean America
and yeah they were brutal and
um and definitely did a lot of nasty
things to people whom they were hoping
to subjugate and also that's not the
only thing they were
yep well I would
the degree to which they were brutal
needs to be thoroughly uh analyzed
because it's it I think uh
my sense is that it is quite different
than the standard anyway we don't have
to dwell here but the degree of the
brutality is well worth a deep dive yeah
okay so
um there are three things that we were
hoping to talk about this week I'm going
to go ahead and start sure okay oh yeah
okay is that okay yes I'm just making
sure that I'm not forgetting to do
something that needs to be done but I
believe we are we are where we need to
be
um last week on episode 163 the final
thing we talked about was uh the the
newest way that Scott Adams was making
the news right that he had read a poll
that claimed that nearly half of black
people who were asked don't feel safe
around white people he advised white
people to move away from black people
into their own neighborhoods we talked
about this uh and we talked about the
fact that he is advancing the cause of
segregation
and you know much ink and you know
Airwaves have been spilled that's not
what happens
uh has I don't know what the right
analogy is
um over this uh you know it's it's been
over a week now and it continues to have
repercussions including that apparently
uh Dilbert's been dropped by you know
almost every newspaper
um I think it may be all yeah um so um
so that's just something that happened
as a result of um
Scott Adams saying saying what he said
which she talked about last week
um we suggested that this was among
other things Un-American uh what he was
proposing and wait wait In fairness what
he was proposing is un-American
the idea that it is not okay to be white
is also Un-American right and I believe
those two things have to travel together
in this story right we're getting there
okay
um so I saw a few comments that um
scoffed at us in response to what we had
said uh including one in particular it
said and this was the the theme of all
of them didn't you guys just move to an
island to escape living near people who
hate you
as if this is a response I mean it is it
is it is posted as if it's a response
and so I have
um and you know the answer is no no we
didn't
um but it raises a couple of interesting
issues that I think are worth us
exploring because although this doesn't
this would not seem to be uh in you know
the Wheelhouse of how to think
scientifically which is a large part of
what we we do here on air we explore
things scientifically I think it
actually makes this point
surprisingly well which is that
so that's the first of two points and
the second um is actually about about
race
um the first then is
um
again the comment and this is just one
of a few that showed up didn't you guys
just move to an island to escape living
near people who hate you
well there's an observable fact we just
moved to an island that is true
did we move to an island to escape
living near people who hate us no no we
didn't uh so there are a lot of reasons
we moved to an island and I think we've
talked about some of them and there are
others that we haven't talked about and
um and we might continue to do so in the
future but that's not the point here
the point is uh that there's an
observable fact we recently moved to an
island and onto that is a uh is an
assertion of interpretation of what our
motives were which are then conflated as
if the fact of the observable fact
inherently means the second thing the
interpretation and this is this is a um
pretty common
um but really important to avoid error
that people make in science and in
interpreting things in general right is
that and and you know specifically since
most of my empirical uh scientific
experience is in the field doing animal
behavior this is absolutely one of the
things that you have to train yourself
to and when you're teaching students to
do animal behavior have to really really
drum into them and no one was going to
be perfect but the point is you're going
out to look at what is happening to see
what is actually happening to observe
what is actually happening and even our
language tends to add interpretations to
it and so I'll give an example from the
work that I did in Madagascar with these
you know I was working on these poison
frogs which have as it turns out I was
the first person to work on them
um you know incredible social systems
with different kinds of territoriality
and these extended fights that can go on
for like more than an hour and it's
really intricate courtship and a lot of
Parental care like all of these things
which
I had
hypothesized and if I'm being honest
hoped that I might see but if it wasn't
true it wasn't true that's you know
that's the way of nature but when I
first went because because
um the not closely related but very
um similar in terms of some of the other
aspects of who they are dark poison
frogs in the new world do these things
that was part of why I hypothesized that
I might be seeing these things but when
I first went and I marked the frogs and
so I knew who I was looking at
and I would see them you know to what I
understood to be males wrestling with
one another for a very long time
it was important that I not write into
my notes but
now that seems like it's ridiculous
right why do I have to go through all of
that trouble to write down exactly what
I'm seeing and some of it I recorded on
video but really describing actually
what what is happening and who's doing
what to whom who's on top of whom who's
chasing whom who's you know knocking
whom off the piece of bamboo and over
time
I came to be able to say okay I have
these types of fights and now when I see
this thing that I've carefully defined
over here I can say okay that's that's
this type of fight and I can just write
that into my notes while I'm watching
and I can know for sure that what I was
seeing was this
but I had to spend a lot of time
watching first because if I just started
out by saying well obviously that's a
fight
then when I say later ah well I always
saw these fights between such and such
individuals under these conditions
there's no way for anyone including
myself to know if I actually know what
I'm talking about because I've added the
interpretation in in the beginning I've
I've encoded my interpretation of what I
thought I was seeing and conflated it
with
inextricably interwoven it with the
interpretation and at that point you
don't have data anymore you have your
interpretation and you can't find the
data separate from the interpretation
and you really have to go back to step
one and start everything from scratch
and this is um
in order to do scientific work well the
mind is sort of built for science but it
is not built for the formalisms that are
required to do it well right it's built
to informally do something scientific
yeah and the the formal part actually
requires you to break normal human
habits right so as as I think we've
discussed before
the mind works based on
hundreds of probably thousands of
heuristics even the visual system works
based on heuristics where you're not
processing everything pixel by pixel
you're processing Things based on you
know things that our tables tend to look
like tables and uh anyway the point is
it makes doing the difficult stuff
possible by skipping all of the stuff by
making assumptions that tend to be a
good bet which is why optical illusions
are so interesting because you can
detect any place where you have a
perfect ambiguity between two
interpretations the heuristic will
wobble back and forth or it will pick
one and not be able to see the other
whatever it is
um so the point is look heuristics are
the key to not being paralyzed by the
number of things that you would
otherwise have to analyze but but in
order to figure out something that's
truly difficult you're on an island far
away or truly new right completely new
to you and you're trying to map it onto
things that you already know like that's
that's the error and what you're after
is really stuff that isn't intuitive and
obvious right right the the important
stuff that comes out of the investment
in what we call science is the stuff
that you didn't know to expect right and
so in order to do that well you have to
train yourself out of Leaping to the
conclusion that what you're seeing just
maps onto the heuristic that would
ordinarily take care of it right and so
I really like your point here about yes
we moved to an island and you know it
wasn't about uh it's not entirely wrong
that uh the on discomfort with what was
going on on the mainland had something
to do with it but it was not about
moving away from people who didn't like
us we'll get to that's that point is the
second point but let's just let's just
stick with with this first okay
well I mean I I think we more or less
got there the point is breaking the bad
habit of Leaping to conclusions is the
key to actually seeing things that you
didn't walk into the situation knowing
yes yeah no that's that's right and um I
guess I I did want to say a couple
things about
um you know some of our some of our
reasoning which is you know we don't
need to explain and isn't necessary to
respond here
um is that you know our our perception
that Global Systems are becoming less
stable
and um that we've been dreaming about
these islands since we first came and
visited them 17 years ago or so 18 years
ago now something like that
and um and frankly the coyotes were
driving us crazy I'm talking about
actual coyotes like wild canids and uh
the the the number of coyotes in
Portland was insane yeah and that sounds
like a trivial thing but it was actually
you have cats and you go Outdoors it's
not trivial um yeah
um
and you know is
is it true uh that there are some people
in Portland who who don't like us yeah
it's true but I will say that one you
know one of I miss Portland I've said
this before and I've gone back a couple
times since we moved away and I continue
when I'm back there to have the
experience that we were increasingly
having before we left which is
um not once in Portland if either of us
um had someone come up to us and berate
us
um but
I don't know one and two one and three
times that one of us would go out and
someone would come up to us to say Thank
you so
um I mean if anything it was it was the
opposite sort of sort of move but the
second Point uh is what if we had like
what what if that had been the reason
that we had moved can I pause you there
because I do want to put some uh some
flesh on these bones surrounding
the concern about Portland okay
it is very different okay so there are
people in Portland who hate us no doubt
who cares well we have to care because
what happened in Portland that literally
is where we're going oh okay well I
don't know that I thought you were
moving on to this other point but well
that but that okay you talked about this
like this this is the other point the
other point is what if we had done this
like what if what if the reason to move
which it was but what if the reason to
move had been to get away from people
who don't like us
would this be the same thing as what
Scott Adams was advising no
explicitly and formally not because
taking action to protect yourself
again specific and particular threats
from real people
is not just reasonable it would be
foolish to not do so right to not
consider the fact that there might
actually be real risks against you right
and imagining that that shouldn't be
part of your understanding of the world
is not just naive but beyond foolish
whereas
lumping in all people of certain
demographic markers as having a certain
set of beliefs and acting as if you know
what that group will do is ascribing
individual level beliefs to a population
and imagine that you know what the
entire group thinks and that pretty much
is the definition of racist it's no more
racist than what the you know survey
suggested a bunch of people were
thinking who were answering the survey
right
um it's it's racist either way but it is
absolutely not the same thing to
understand yourself as being in a
situation where there are individuals
who are very interested in doing you
harm
as opposed to saying oh I know those
sorts of people those sorts of people
um don't like my sort of people and so
therefore I'm going to separate myself
from them really totally fundamentally
different actions
totally fundamentally different all
right I am going to go back and make
this point I don't think it's yeah I
don't think it's the point that you're
getting at here
who cares that people in Portland didn't
like us
I care do you know why because
those who govern Portland stopped
enforcing the law they basically
prevented the police from showing up
they allowed the police to be demonized
the Police Stopped showing up so it
shouldn't matter that you live in a city
where people hate you
mostly our experience in Portland was
very positive the fact that there are a
small number of people who hate us
shouldn't matter because in general the
law protects you from that but if your
city government stops enforcing the law
that's a serious problem
so anyway I just want to put that on the
table the problem wasn't people who
don't like us who were there in tiny
numbers the problem was the governance
of the thing which made the city frankly
not tenable in the long term you can't
not enforce the law and have a city
continue to function and it was visibly
deteriorating as a result of this that's
one thing and we and we talked a lot
especially during the summer and fall of
2020 about the ways in which the law was
not being enforced and one of one of the
ways that that happened was of course
you know the all cops are bastards
campaign and the
um chief of the police
cannot believe that we were there and
you know mostly those policies have been
reversed across the across the cities
where they happened but also just
providing so little support for people
who were actually employed in law
enforcement that they they left in
droves right like people people retired
early they left and laid left to either
go be police elsewhere where they were
going to actually have some chance of of
being appreciated or they found new work
and then the recruitment effort started
it's like come be police and yeah like a
lot of really awesome people are going
to choose to take on a job where you are
under a tremendous amount of stress and
physical risk all the time and you are
going to be the one blamed almost no
matter what if something bad happens and
the same blamed means you actually could
end up in prison for a shooting that
under normal circumstances where there
was not hysteria around something like
race
a shooting that had to happen because
it's in the normal course of policing as
a result of the fact that somebody is
threatening somebody else with a deadly
weapon or whatever such a circumstance
could turn around on you in Portland as
a result of the fact that the narrative
was the problem here is the police and
the city government
um I think cynically went along with
that Insanity which made it dangerous
and yeah blame blame is a weak word here
yes held responsible for anything that
anything bad that might happen which
isn't to say that there isn't bad
policing but of course you know if if
that's going to be the Assumption uh
then it's a crazy place to take up that
work so yes the recruitment effort uh
was ridiculous
um okay second point I wanted to make is
uh and it's something I felt I should
have said last week
the the most troubling thing to me about
what Scott Adams said was
something closing in on half of the
people responding which as you and I
discussed the survey uh methodology is
not really defensible it was a tiny
survey and it was a voluntary
self-reports so okay what does it mean
that something like closing in on half
but you really want to abandon the
population in which more than half of
the people are on your team even if it
was only 25 of the black respondents to
this survey who had said it was okay to
be white you really want to abandon
those people isn't that the time when it
is most important to align yourself and
to recognize that it's your duty as an
American to stand up for other Americans
who are in the minority and jeopardized
so in any case the more you look at what
he said the more uncareful it is
relative to even if you took the
evidence at face value
yeah and I guess I will just repeat that
he is responding with racism to race
with racism to races I mean responding
to racism with racism the what is
reported in the survey if it's real
is Downstream again if it's real if
there's close to half of black people
who are saying yeah no like not
good uh with with people who don't look
like us
um that is Downstream of
some out of historic racism
um right but a whole lot of the woke
ideology that passes itself off as about
you know love and rainbows and unicorns
and is actually divisive and
fundamentally racist itself and so and
you know and you did say this last week
of course one of the results of such a
crackpot ideology that is inherently
racist and is pretending to be
anti-racist is going to be that people
who weren't racist who aren't buying the
ideology but are watching people get
radicalized around them will themselves
become radicalized and become more
racist like that is going to be the
result of this kind of ideology taking
over and people will be less able to
talk to one another as individuals and
more likely to focus on demographic
markers that you can't change and
accident of birth becomes much more
important than what you make of yourself
health and if you know it's it's the end
of Merit it's the end of kindness and
frankly it's the end of humanity
certainly the end of America
um I I do want to say oh America too
okay yeah yeah
um I
I
for me
the jury is still out as to whether or
not what Adam said is motivated by
racism I actually don't see that as
necessary I think it was very uncareful
and very unwise
um but I didn't I did not attribute a
mental state to him I said the
pronouncement is racist
it is I think functionally raised I
think that's a distinction that is is
worth making in part because some of
what is coming out of the woke ideology
uh will say that it doesn't matter at
all what your intention was if you know
this this thing is inherently uh racist
and I will say you know in general I
don't I don't buy that but
arguing that uh that you should separate
yourself
um by race is a racist pronouncement
whether or not it's motivated by a
belief in the superiority um of or fear
of One race or another you have
compelled me you're right that it's it
is actually not necessary that it be
motivated by a
um
a racist ideology or emotional impulse
but the point is my point about it being
less than half yeah
um and again even if it had been 75
percent right it is it is our duty as
decent human beings to stand by the 25
who aren't saying that right
um but in this case what he did the
thing that really did uh strike me as
way off now Scott if you're listening
listen carefully
um was to globalize
um a basically what he said was
specifically get away from black people
on the basis that something less than
half of them in this flawed survey seem
to have indicated that it wasn't okay to
be white so
I agree with you you've persuaded me uh
the statement is racist even if there is
no racism in Scott and I can't say one
way or the other but I don't I don't see
the evidence of it
um so
and just just to return to the first
point because it's it's the one that I
care more deeply about honestly which is
you know just the nature of sense making
like how is it that we understand our
world and uh and you know how how do the
tools of science help and it is it is
this one it is an observation
and the interpretation of the
observation even if the interpretation
of that observation holds 98 of the time
are two different things
and the observation of in this case a
factual recording of like something
happened or if you're going out into the
field with a hypothesis you already have
and you're actually taking data
um conflating what you see what You
observe with your senses biased though
they are to be true and as accurate and
careful and factual a recording of what
happened as possible
is always different from what it means
and I think part of the frankly part of
the
Insanity of summer and fall of 2020 and
of sort of woke ideology in general and
a lot of the propaganda that we were
told around covid was about taking was
about you know someone with an agenda
taking a negative truth and then
wrapping it in an interpretation and
pretending or believing some of each I'm
sure that those two things were
inextricable
and that that became the way that people
got confused and convinced like oh well
uh if if I have to believe all women all
the time then okay then that accusation
must be true
oh if um I know I know that vaccines are
safe therefore these vaccines must be
safe right like there there were just
there were these tricks constantly
around taking something that you know
may even not have been true but like
that you believe fundamentally and
wrapping it in another thing wrapping in
the interpretation and then presenting
it as if it's a single thing so I mean
me that to me that became one of the
things that I was thinking about a lot
this week having seen these comments and
like everyone has to whenever being told
anything go okay
is what you're being told the thing that
they actually know
or or do they know or do they not know
anything which is often the case right
or do they know something but they have
added on to that something and it's that
add-on that's actually the thing that's
making you insane right the thing that
is why you can't communicate and you
know this happens interpersonally right
um and everyone who's ever talked to
another human being who's ever cared
about another human being and has
therefore come back at some point been
like wait why'd you do that what
happened like why were you having this
argument right
um well often at least some part of the
argument will come down to like people
you said this like no I didn't say that
what I said was X and I see how you
could have heard that that meant why but
what I said was X and you know no I'm
not being a pet ant here and this isn't
just semantics because if if like if if
both of you are being honest and both of
you do actually have a good memory
and you can go back and say oh okay I
see now why you're angry with me because
you think that I believe this thing and
it took you down that road but what I
said was actually careful and no I
wasn't even trying to leave my options
open I didn't even understand that that
was an interpretation you could have had
for my words so you know language is
obviously different from you know
observation of like move to an island
um you know male frog on top of male
frog
um you know riding it around while the
Frog underneath calls
um like those are different kinds of
observations then like he was a word and
words are so often metaphorically when
they seem like they're not
still
with language in particular we will add
our own interpretations for what that
meant as a sort of a shorthand for
encoding and downstream of that lies so
many of our disagreements yeah so you
got to exactly one of the points I
wanted to highlight here which is this
is another case of
um it's not exactly a heuristic but it's
the same thing that creates heuristics
that trips you up where the point is
do you you know let's say you're reading
a book
do you want to remember it verbatim
that's a lot of hard disk space that
that's going to take up in your mind do
you want to remember you know the plot
in some condensed way that you can
recover it and discuss it but you don't
have every word right and so the point
is the efficiency gain you get from
editing things down to their meaning is
spectacular but in interpersonal
Communications where it's not even
something that the author has carefully
scrutinized and said yes this is exactly
what I wish to say but it's something
you said off the cuff it's very easy for
the other person
to say okay I understand what they said
here is the meaning they remember it and
then when they have to remember recall
what it was that was said they will
extrapolate back to what must have been
said from a meaning that may have been I
don't know what you said right I'll
actually often means I know what you
meant it's like well how how could you
help or I know what I understood you to
mean at the time and it would have
sounded like this and then it's like
well I didn't say that and so this is a
very normal thing and of course you know
people have studied this in courtrooms
right right you know uh many times
multiple witnesses will have very
different versions of events
um but I also wanted to point out that
um humans are a special case
you the process you were talking about
with the frogs where you walk into a
bamboo stand and you don't leap to the
conclusion it's just because it looks
like a fight it is a fight it may well
be in fact that's the most likely thing
it's going to be but and over time and
repeated observations over weeks and
months you can say okay I have now
categorized I now have my categories and
they might not be right but here we go
you compel yourself and the great thing
about this is if you do it right right
at the point that you stand up in front
of a room of people and you present the
thing that nobody knew before and people
say wait a minute and then yeah but how
do you know that was a fight and you say
well here's how I know that was a fight
and here you know and so the point you
can recover how it is you became
compelled to the thing that you think is
a fight actually is one and it's all
very robust very often you don't know
who's making sense until you push them
around just a simple fact oh that's
important yeah yes very often you don't
know who's making sense until you push
them around yeah and very often this but
in academic settings but I think in all
settings but we've just seen it more in
academic settings you can just tell the
difference between the person who's like
well there's no time for questions like
I don't know I don't know that someone
else did that part of the work I do want
to one thing people are going to jump on
us but you don't have people on Dark
Horse who disagree with you no this is
something that requires good faith and
frankly in many cases we don't know who
has who is acting in good faith and so
I'm not arguing that you are forced to
confront every sophist and pet Aunt who
wants to attack you I'm just saying you
can tell when two honest interlocutors
interact you can see whether people know
what they're talking about it's it's
clear well and and frankly having um you
know again not this week not next week
but you know having live q and A's in
which people are people we don't know
ask questions and you know we don't get
to all of them and occasionally we look
at one and say that's that we're not
going to read that out loud yep um but
uh you know we invite questions from
from our audience every week almost
okay but the thing I wanted to recover
here is you and I have said many times
that often
in order to understand what's taking
place in a human interaction you need to
effectively turn the sound all the way
down right and so the
type specimen for this kind of problems
let's say that you're watching a uh a
dispute between people who are
romantically involved
there is a lot that is said right and
that what is said it's very hard not to
process it and if you process it then
you're going to try to track the details
of the he should said she said and it
may not add up and you can't recover an
explanation of what actually must have
taken place in order for these two
different perspective to exist on the
other hand if you turn down the sound
and you treat it primatologically it's
often very clear what's going on right
yeah somebody's hurt there's an act of
contrition it's not sufficient whatever
you know the point is it's
straightforward at one level and the
words are confusing you actively right
so that's obviously not true in every
situation presumably in international
relations there's a bit of that but
there's also a bit of what exactly does
that treaty say you know but
anyway the idea that
um the human mind can be misled by
meaning that is irrelevant to the
underlying issue is absolutely crucial
and uh it's it's a tough lesson to learn
but once you learn it you'll realize oh
maybe this is one of those situations
yeah absolutely
is that all uh I believe that is all on
that topic for me all right uh so
you also wanted
a couple things you want to talk about
Daniel Ellsberg yes I did oh
was the
oh do you you tell me if when you wanted
to
um or if you wanted
up to you so why don't you this is this
is your topic why don't you introduce
okay so um who is Daniel many of you
will know who Daniel Ellsberg is but for
those who don't Daniel Ellsberg is the
person who released the Pentagon papers
and in
1973 I think 69
the book came out in 71-72 I looked it
up I uh I may have it wrong I may have
the date wrong but I thought his
leadership history uh was in 73. he was
he was an indict under indictment
maybe early and
no in any case doesn't really matter the
time started reporting began published
in the series of articles in 71. 71. and
uh they contain a history of the U.S
role in into China
through his legal Jeopardy is what I was
responding to I think that's a little
bit later but anyway the point is
Ellsberg decided to release
papers that were if you think about the
way government works right if you have
an entity the CIA the Pentagon whatever
you would need to have some repository
of institutional knowledge right and the
institutional knowledge can't be if it's
an entity that isn't telling the full
story to the public or isn't even
telling a true story to the public the
institution has to internally understand
what happened in order that it doesn't
become confused later right
um and so anyway what he got a hold of
was the pentagon's internal description
of how Vietnam had proceeded how we had
ended up at War there and what it all
meant and it was explosive right it was
absolutely devastating to the public
narrative and it revealed uh
duplicitousness
um on the part of the Johnson
Administration but in any case
revealing this was obviously in
retrospect at least
a protected activity right this was
journalism and the fact that this was
very destructive to the federal
government's narrative is beside the
point it was you know this was a
journalistically justifiable release but
it didn't mean that Ellsberg didn't end
up in major Jeopardy and he did he was
threatened with I think the Espionage
Act and he lived in fear that he would
be locked away and in fact he in what
happened uh this week he talks a little
bit about uh the Jeopardy that he felt
and that he thought he might live for
the rest of his life Behind Bars more or
less as Julian Assange finds himself
um but anyway so he's a very courageous
interesting patriotic guy he also is an
important intellectual contributor to
the world which I didn't realize until I
started uh looking back into his history
and it turns out that even before the
Pentagon papers he contributed uh
basically a description of an important
Paradox and the Paradox is that people
tend to prefer
actually it's a rumsfeldian paradox long
before there was a a an important uh
Rumsfeld but the idea is that people
tend to prefer to take risks that are
known or that they think are known
uh above risks that are unknown even if
the risks that are known are much
greater than the unknown risks are
likely to be
right so that there is a basically a
cognitive defect where people sense that
they can quantify the size of the risk
will cause them to take on more risk
than they need to that the expected
return might be better on the well here
are some things we really can't say that
branch of the tree may be a better bet
but people are reluctant to do it
which is
highly relevant I believe to much that
has taken place under covid for example
that we may even have been played by
people who understood this Paradox well
I've never heard this before and so I
don't know if I'm understanding
um correctly but it sounds like there's
an the additional concern is certainty
versus uncertainty
right and I mean that that's maybe just
built right into the thing but it
strikes me that that isn't
it isn't inherently a paradox because
you're saying known risk
probably lower payoff versus unknown
risk maybe higher payoff but you know
the devil is in the maybe is in is in
the odds
um no let's take an example and Daniel
if you're out there and I hope you are
there's uh Lots I'd love the opportunity
to say to you including thanks but um
let's take the example of uh do you get
an mRNA vaccine
or do you face covet you know back in
the days when you thought that that was
a choice rather than oh you're going to
get the MRNA vaccine and then you're
going to get coveted anyway which is
what we now know is the case but unless
you choose to get the vaccine right
um
so
if you have the sense that oh well I can
quantify the risk of a bad event from
the vaccines because they were studied
by Pfizer in advance of the release I
have no idea what the risks of covet are
that's a brand new thing right and the
point is actually your risks from covid
might be much lower because if you
calculate it out well it is a virus and
we are built to handle viruses that
we've never seen before and yeah this is
a funny one but
um well this this strikes me as a
strange example though because the
certainty the certain side of this one
um was fabricated oh it's right
if it's not it was not only was the
certainty fabricated but the valence was
opposite well that's what that's why I'm
saying that this may have been used
actually to game us that people who
understood that we would recoil from the
unknowns of some new virus and that we
would you know recoil into the hands of
a pseudo-quantified study that
said that this stuff was safe and
effective right they may have understood
that that was coming or maybe not maybe
they just demonstrated the principle
without understanding it I think that's
plausible on the basis that they may
have evolved this Behavior it may be
emergent or they may have been fully
aware I don't know but
um
but in any case back to Ellsberg so
Ellsberg has made intellectual
contributions he certainly made a major
contribution to American history in
um releasing the Pentagon papers and
putting himself in very serious Jeopardy
over them and then he also was targeted
by Nixon's plumbers in the Watergate
scandal remember what plumber means they
fix leaks they fix leaks exactly and so
anyway they targeted Ellsberg so he is
an important historical figure I will
also say it is a matter of Pride to me
that early in our being in the public
eye
he began following me on Twitter and I
always felt like you know to have a
historically important figure like that
somebody with deep courage follow meant
something to me
anyway I was struck when he uh announced
on Twitter this week
um he published a letter that he had
delivered to
um his allies and friends in the anti
anti-war and anti-nuclear movements
right the anti-warrant anti-nuclear
movements that revealed that he has been
diagnosed with terminal pancreatic
cancer pancreatic cancer there are a
couple kinds but apparently he has the
kind about which there's essentially
nothing that can be done and has a very
short time Horizon
um and so
on the one hand that is tragic
um
on the other hand I thought that the
grace with which he handled it was so
extraordinary that
um
it actually raised some other questions
which I think are worth addressing
I'm going to just share a tiny bit from
the first the first tweet which do you
want me to put it up you may do that if
you if you like so this is his first he
says I wrote this letter recently to my
friends in as we said in the anti-war
and anti-nuclear movements I see it's
being circulated so I've decided to
share it here for all of you working on
these issues thank you and please keep
going
so he says what Brett has just described
um I'm sorry to report to them my
doctors have given me three to six
months to live of course they emphasize
that everyone's case is individual it
might be more or less
I have chosen not to do chemotherapy
which offers no promise and I have
Assurance of great hospice care when
needed please know right now I am not in
any physical pain and in fact after my
hip replacement surgery in late 2021 I
feel better physically than I have in
years moreover my cardiologist has given
me license to abandon my salt-free diet
in the last six years this has improved
my quality of life dramatically the
pleasure of eating my former favorite
foods and my energy level is high
so
I don't know how much you want me to
share of this but he goes on I think I
think that's probably sufficient to get
the gist of it
um
so this brought a number of things to
mind one he reveals he is uh 90 he'll be
92 on April 7th he's closing in on 92.
and so what is one to make of a
terminal diagnosis at 92. I mean a he's
passed the life expectancy certainly for
somebody uh born in
one
all right
um anyway
um
he is he has lived a full life he's
lived an extraordinary life and he's
made real contributions and he now finds
himself faced with the end of his life
and he
is feeling good
and this put me in mind of a couple
things
one it put me in mind of the
extraordinary year that we had with your
father after his
um first of two heart attacks the second
one took his life
the first one
um
basically not to go back into the story
which we've talked about elsewhere but
um was so severe that the paramedics
told us that he was gone
upon seeing our children present
continued to work on him and then
revised their uh diagnosis later and we
did not know that he would come out of
the coma that they put him into they
cooled him down but so just just briefly
uh you came to the door with are then
seven and five-year-old
would have been Sons
and the paramedics had just told my
mother and me that he was gone they've
been working on it for 20 minutes his
heart had been stopped for at least that
long
um
and uh they started working on him again
upon seeing basically the Next
Generation who were there to who loved
their grandfather deeply and and they
saved his life and he we had another
year with him somehow they I guess the
younger that was 11 years ago so that
would have been they were younger they
were six and four two little boys at the
door yeah yeah but in any case whatever
the particulars he
came back he was shaken by the
experience but he was himself and
um the year that we had and it was
really almost exactly a year uh was a
tremendous blessing because
he knew
the fragile state he was in and we all
knew the fragile state that he was in
and so many of the things that needed to
be said God said and you know it was
absent that year would have been a very
different loss I think
so anyway I I'm you know thinking
there are a lot worse things to happen
to you than to get a diagnosis that
gives you three to six months to close
out your business and the fact is at
that age you kind of got to expect it's
coming at some point so
um so anyway uh kudos to to Daniel for
confronting it this way it also put me
in mind of this uh
you know the Norm Macdonald story which
I find are McDonald who I was also
honored to be followed by
um Norm Macdonald
had terminal cancer and he did something
very unusual which is he decided to tell
no one and in so doing
he preserved the end of his life so that
it was not overrun by everybody every
minute that they were talking to him
thinking I'm talking to somebody who's
about to disappear on me and it struck
me as unusual but very much something
that somebody should entertain and so
anyway I think the way Daniel Ellsberg
is handling this is a model of a a way
to deal with such a thing that's uh
marvelous he's not giving himself false
hope he's eating salt and the dangers of
salt have been overrated so you know
um it's uh it's about uh it's probably
about time that he took up eaten salt
again
um but it in any case
it's a profound moment for all of us and
that we get to share the end of his life
with him I think is uh is Meaningful
it's a it's a great way
um for a historical figure to
um to put a bookend on his own legacy
yeah
and I had one more thing I wanted to add
in as long as we're talking about death
and sort of what the adult viewpoint on
it might be this is
not
um particularly related to Ellsberg but
it's a thought that I've had
increasingly and I think it belongs on
the table because frankly I think it
might have the potential
to save some lives
um so anyway I'm open to pushback on
this but
um here's the thought
the thought has to do with
the the
mental process that I think leads many
people who are in great Pain to End
their lives
and what I realized is that I hadn't
heard the following thing that I'm
almost certain
within bounds that it's true which is
that
death
can very definitely end suffering
but it cannot bring relief
and I suspect that many people who end
their lives
are not doing so simply to end a torment
that will never stop right obviously if
you are in terrible pain and there's no
hope of recovering then ending suffering
may be a perfectly valid uh thing to to
need and to want
but I believe many people who do this
are probably pursuing
a relief that our minds tell us would be
there and logically just simply can't
um and so in any case I think that spell
out as as spell out why logically relief
can't come with death
because there is because relief is a
somatic experience it's a cognitive
experience and to the extent that your
cognition comes to an end there is no
relief to be had and there is one caveat
I will put on this which is
and I believe many people who end their
own lives convince themselves quite
falsely that their life is
um burdensome on others
what they don't realize is that the in
most people's cases the loss of somebody
especially the traumatic loss to suicide
is extremely burdensome it's it's a
burden that uh loved ones often don't
get past
um but uh the
the caveat is you you know in my own
case if my continued existence was more
of a burden to my family than my exit
and there was no chance that it was
going to turn around right then I don't
have any continued reason to want to
continue and their relief could be
something but for most people the idea
that I just need some relief from this
suffering that's a non-sequitur in in
the case of of death especially by ones
on hand and
I thought it was worth uh just simply
expressing that in the hope that
maybe some someone or
multiple people contemplating
their own predicament might realize that
actually the way they'd been thinking of
it was wrong and that the best thing to
do is to confront the suffering itself
and not
not take up arms against it as
Shakespeare put it yeah
well there's no real good segue
uh apologies no no we put it in this I
got the Segway okay sorry I hate I hate
to have done this to you Daniel because
I've now taken that piece which is
isolated from your story which triggered
me to uh to explore it but I did want to
say to Daniel Ellsberg
um
as an American a deeply heartfelt thank
you for what you've done and uh I hope
what time you have left is glorious and
fulfilling and that all the things that
need to be said get set so in any case
thank you
I concur that's awesome
but that's not a segue
um you've given what you want to talk
about next that's not a segue that's not
a segue
okay
um
right yeah no I see the problem the
problem yeah we got a whole uh
well let's hope that everybody takes a
bathroom break you and I will
um
uh we'll segue in 14 seconds
um I I you have to introduce this okay
this is totally different segment
totally different mindset
okay many of you will be aware of the
person I never quite remember how she
pronounced her name I think it's Ayla
um her Twitter handle is
uh Ayla underscore girl yep
um
Ayla has made quite a name for herself
I will say
I appreciate one thing that Ayla does
Ayla who describes herself as autistic
has specialized in
essentially
publicly sorting out uncomfortable
topics she runs polls if you ask people
questions that no one will ask and these
things often have a
[Music]
um
I have found useful uh consequence right
causing people to think carefully about
stuff that their minds tend to avoid
there have certainly been cases where
she's asked stuff that just feels like
oh geez why would you even go there but
um but any in any case I will say that
there is a part of me that appreciates
that aspect of what she's doing but in
this case
Ayla has
um gone on a
rant a multi-tweet thread I've got a
couple to read if you want yeah let me
just say what she is uh clearly
exasperated that what she has been doing
and talking about has resulted in other
people who she regards as a traditional
or dismisses as traditional has caused
them to respond negatively to her and
anyway uh why don't you read a few but I
think you you buried the lead which is
that I don't know if she's a sex worker
or she's just
um
or or just I don't even know what the
other what the just would be but so I'm
gonna even though we swear here
sometimes I'm gonna I'm gonna just
Allied the the cursing so the opening
tweet is okay what the f is going on
with the neotrads I was just over here
enjoying this free life individualism
subversive unwo cultural movement and I
thought everybody was on board but
suddenly bam we got a bunch of them
spawning into sex negative tradcats or
whatever
I don't know what kath is I don't either
um and then a couple later it's it's a
not a too long a thread but a couple of
the
um Tweets in the thread that struck me
as particularly
uh indicative of what she's on about
um this reminds me of this is again
Ayla
um if that's how you pronounce your name
um on her little tweet rant as I think
she describes it
um this reminds me of the time I joined
to lurk some Trad Christian chat room
and I actually didn't did it under my
Ayla name and the Christian sent me DMS
threatening me that if I tried to seduce
any of the men there they'd ban me but
like why would I want to seduce them
in their terrified little Minds I'm a
she demon prowling hornily around their
frantically buttoned jeans cackling on a
man inevitably surrenders to his Primal
nature sucking the morality out of his
little chunk and scampering off with his
hard-earned 401k
so I read those two because they strike
me as
um just
really inconsistent with one another in
terms of for someone who is
supposedly very self-aware of of her
impact on the world
um I joined to Lark some Trad Christian
chat room and like why would I want to
seduce them yeah
why would they assume you didn't
like what are you what are you doing
there you just use the word lurk and
Trad Christian chat room and
um anyway you had you had a number of
things you wanted to say about well yes
so first off I actually you know I don't
know whether
Ayla is for Real okay the fact is she
has broadcast something into social
media space that
um
definitely makes a stir and she is
monetizing it
and
part of what her online
Persona is is somebody who is deeply
interested in the underlying truth of
things like the you know the truths
around sex for example
to the extent that this is for Real
right that this is really just who she
is and that whatever errors she may be
making they're Honestly made
I actually think she deserves an answer
as to why people would be upset by what
she is doing and you know whether or not
they are in some sense Justified to be
upset because there's something to be
upset about or whether they are as she
portrays it simply infringing on her
Freedom as a human who is entitled to do
what they want as long as she doesn't
violate the law right
um so anyway I sort of wanted to take up
the challenge and you know just describe
why it might be that people would be
upset and not without some cause and I
wanted to revisit
something I happened to see if she
tweeted uh maybe a couple weeks back and
she was talking so she's uh of course
polyamorous and she was talking about
um how she uh not only is she gonna go
screw other people while she's in a
relationship with somebody but she would
be kind of turned on if her
partner was also getting laid right
um and
so anyway this is the kind of vibe that
she's putting out and you know let's
steal that
the fact is you're a human being
you're the descendant of some species
you get one life
there's obviously something good about
Freedom ooh is in a position to tell you
how to value your sexual self right if
you feel like going to orgies and
behaving this way who gets to tell you
not to that's kind of the question right
and I don't think it's I think it's kind
of a profound question right you get one
life when we tell you you can't do
something there better be a good reason
right and so that's the question is is
there a good reason or as she puts it in
that first tweet
is the right way for us to view this hey
or maybe maybe actually it was in a
tweet you didn't read
she basically says look I'm perfectly
fine with you behaving in a traditional
way I have no problem with monogamous
people just so long as you have no
problem with what I'm doing right and so
that's the question is do does either
Camp get to comment on what the other
Camp is doing for good reason or is that
an infringement in either direction
okay are there externalities uh that
that can't be abided
either of these sets of behaviors that's
exactly what I think this conversation
does
um so let us first just notice the
following thing
in an ancestral circumstance right so we
none of us can be hunter-gatherers right
it's actually just not legal you can't
take up hunting and Gathering because
you need a hunting permit and a
gathering permit and where would you do
it and you know you're either on public
land or private land and so the point is
civilization took that
uh that Birthright of yours and
it took it away and it gave you some
things in exchange it gave you leverage
in the world right you're much less
likely to starve there's a police force
that unless you live in Portland will
show up if somebody tries to hurt you
right that kind of thing
um
but so the point is
um you give up some freedoms in
Civilization and you get some stuff and
I wanted to point out first about before
we get to any of the externality stuff
if somebody decided to deploy
ayla's program in some past circumstance
a thousand years ago 10 000 years ago
it'd be a pretty short ride
because it'd end up almost immediately
pregnant and uh if they weren't careful
about how that happened they would end
up raising Offspring alone or depending
heavily on family and so there's a
reason that all of those ancient
cultures and in fact every culture
that's ever been has had rules about
sexuality and how you deploy it right
that's not window dressing that's not
inherently oppression if I may it may be
that sort of the the core tension is
what do we do with the freedoms that are
made available by technology
that's it
so to the extent that one can control
their own conception of offspring that
that opens up a whole range of
possibilities the question is are those
all open to you to choose or does
civilization have an interest in saying
actually here's the way we're going to
address this and I would just point out
you know you and I have described that
there is a subtle difference between the
world that you and I were born into and
the modern world in the sense that
people there are no longer any rules
just because you're married doesn't mean
you're not on the
mating and dating Market who knows maybe
you're polyamorously married and you're
available to somebody else right so the
point is you everybody is potentially
fair game right older men targeting
younger women hey that's fine as long as
they're 18 right
it's all on the table is that good
or is that actually harmful to what
civilization is about
and so okay birth control makes it
possible to do a great many things that
would not have been possible in a prior
Circumstance the question is should we
be limited either self-limited by
morality or limited by rules in some
other uh way and I think the argument
the argument I would make and I'm sure
the argument you would make is
definitely yes that there are limits
whatever the mechanism of those limits
uh is there are limits and well we get
back to a conversation we had a couple
weeks ago about not wanting a lot of
what we are about as humans we don't
want to live in the law it's it's too
permanent it's too hard it's too it's
too difficult to change
and so so we use
things like morality and shame and
appreciation and supports and you know
and and the lack of support in order to
you know nudge and move and
um create a world in which we all can do
within limits
that which is best for us while also
impinging the least on others absolutely
and I think this is
um in the moment
very much the most important point which
is
there are limits
we can navigate them but there are also
different levels it's it's in fact a
failure when we have to do these things
by law because nothing else will suffice
and in most cases we have to this point
been pretty good at we Humanity has been
pretty good at setting limits for
ourselves and enforcing them based on
things like you know shame and guilt and
stuff like that so I I wanted to just
point out this thing which is
Fallen away from the discussion around
sex in a way that it is it never ceases
to amaze me as an evolutionary biologist
right sex is obviously something Way
Beyond
reproduction for humans and that is
evolutionarily true Evolution made
humans uh enjoy sex when it is not
reproductive and that is an adaptation
right so that is a major evolutionary
change it's uh it's a godsend it's all
sorts of wonderful things but but the
point is that doesn't mean that the
fundamental
right it's you know we have this
reproductive event that has been
Borrowed by selection for all kinds of
other important stuff and it's not
trivial that's part of the problem is
the trivializing of this
so
here's the central thing what Ayla is
doing
basically
um
takes civilizations fundamental purpose
and I say that without fear of
contradiction it's fundamental purpose
and Sidelines which is
uh the
production of a stable environment that
allows it to continue into the Future
Okay in other words the purpose of
civilization are
children and generations yet to come you
know we are the
temporary custodians of something
precious that literally stretches back
three and a half billion years
and
our civilization is the current
manifestation of this and if our primary
job is not understood to be making that
possible to continue then we up
right and so the the frustrating thing
about what Ayla is saying is
all else being equal
you as a human born under the Earth with
a clock ticking before you go
could be as free as possible but as free
as possible does not mean free to do
anything and everything it means within
reasonable limits where we have an
interest in regulating Behavior maybe
not by law maybe just by tradition
but that has to come first and to the
extent that what Ayla is doing is
monetizing sexuality she may be doing
something else maybe this is fulfilling
to her or maybe it's just about money
but it doesn't really matter the point
is it's really bad
for the raising of children right the
idea that we're going to take sexuality
and we are going to turn it into this a
la carte thing that anybody can
re-envision in any way
is definitely a threat to the much more
constrained version of this in which
people partner long term for the
production of a home that is hospitable
to the raising of children who are then
well equipped for the world that they
emerge into and that stability
creates the room
for the remarkable things about humans
that other organisms don't do it creates
the room
for art and creativity and Science and
Analysis and Discovery and exploration
and innovation
under times of no stability you don't
have time for any of that and
maybe you get more sex with more people
maybe I'm not even convinced of that
long term right but
it's stability I think will be trotted
out by um
by people who make these sorts of
arguments as boring as stayed as Trad
Ed and I guess I would say to the degree
that I still feel compelled to defend
Enlightenment values understanding you
know more in the last few years about
some of the ways that the enlightenment
can be understood to have caused some
problems too but if I am if I'm going to
stand strong in defending Enlightenment
values
which again you know bring in an age of
um of of greater greater wealth across
for more people because of the analysis
The Innovation the discovery and the
creativity that is facilitated therein
that can only happen from a stable base
like that that does not emerge from
Total Chaos
and um that's that's not to say that
um individuals being chaotic don't can't
bring a tremendous insight into the
world uh or that
um after you know the phoenixing of
civilization
um doesn't often produce some of the you
know fastest growth of insight and such
after something like war or genocide
um but you don't need to burn it to the
ground in order to get there
yeah
um in addition to what you're pointing
to which is that a civilization that is
well structured to function to produce
children who are competent and and and
secure
um produces an excess that we can spend
on all of the most marvelous stuff right
that is absolutely true the dark side of
that is that this is also necessary for
the safety of civilization right
civilizations need to be able to sober
up when they are threatened by something
and to the extent that we have turned
civilization into a carnival
we do not have the seriousness of
purpose to handle things like an anime
that you know yeah and and you know and
it is it's it's a carnival it's this
like surface level excitement
and you know where it's it's fast
everything as we talk about in the book
and we talk it's you know it's fast food
fast sex fast media fast everything and
it's titillating
but none of it is as satisfying or
long-term pleasurable
as the non-fast versions and fast is a
stand-in here uh and so you know
yes junk food junk entertainment junk
junk sex that's that's better thank you
um it doesn't it it
standing against that
is not and you know I think it comes up
in this thread as well and as we have
said over and over again as we write in
our book you know the sex positivity
movement
is cleverly but dishonestly named
right that that is that is not actually
um the people who are engaging in the
sex positivity Movement by far do not
have a monopoly on the people who enjoy
sex and indeed uh there are many of us
who will argue that what that does is
goes down a path towards more more junk
sex more objectification
more dehumanization and objectification
dehumanization
are key components in you know really
bad sexual
um environments and and relationships
not the other way around so sex
positivity is actually really bad for
sex as well as humans and everything
else yeah it's and
um I wanted to point out a connection
I'm not sure exactly how to describe it
but
if you think about you have a pleasure
center right let's just oversimplify
this neurobiologically you've got a
pleasure center right it is supposed to
be triggered when you accomplish
something right the Eureka moment
scientists describe right
that is a reward you get for hard work
thinking about something and the
discovery of the answer of it okay it's
one example among many okay you build
something remarkable you invent
something you get a burst of reward
right is it good for the reward center
to be triggered oh yes what happens if
you trigger it without having
accomplished anything
well if you do it too much you'll wreck
your life right this is why uh drugs
that simply trigger that Rush are so
dangerous is that they take the reward
that's supposed to drive you to all
sorts of productive behavior and they
cause it to be connected to a totally
pointless at best activity right and so
the point is that will take somebody who
might otherwise be motivated to do
something productive and maybe great and
will cause them to do nothing useful at
all okay that's the nature of
the pleasure Center and the triggering
of it the triggering of it by short
circuiting the pathway that is supposed
to trigger it yep well guess what
um the pleasure of sex
top of the list of pleasures
um
this is a matter of short-circuiting it
this is like a drug and it's not a
chemical drug but the point is it is
that same idea that hey I've got a
sexual pleasure Center I should be able
to trigger that thing anytime I want
with anyone I want in any way I want and
who's to tell me I can't it's my
pleasure center after all well it's the
same kind of advice as saying you know
you ought to think really careful about
taking you know about having a jar of
Pringles every day having a jar of
Pringles that looks appealing or that
tastes really good going down snorting a
line of coke or whatever it is right any
of these things that short circuit a
fundamental motivator like that is a
danger what's it a danger to well it's a
danger to you but it's also a danger to
civilization and you know as I've
try to make this point civilization used
to run in part for a reason that's very
uncomfortable which was sex was scarce
and in order for men to be worthy of a
sexual relationship they had to impress
they had to be they had to achieve right
I'm not arguing that's how the world
should be structured now that's a very
biased World from a sexual point of view
but
did accomplish a lot of right it
built civilization and so the point is
that was
a motivator from the opposite world
right the world that you are describing
Ayla is a world in which this is
available to anybody who wishes to turn
this into a game and if you make it
available to anybody who is willing to
turn it into a game then many people
especially before they're old enough to
have the wisdom to understand why that
game might be a bad idea are going to
join that game and they're going to have
a very hard time leaving that game so
anyway that is a danger
um to to civilization and I guess the
last thing I would say here is
again I'm not
arguing I really don't know to what
degree
Ayla is reporting her motivations
accurately or to what extent her
motivations are part of the Allure that
she is using to monetize this Persona
that she has built
I don't know and I'm not saying that I
do but what I would point out is this is
not an opportunity that scales
what you are doing Ayla it's definitely
independent
it is fantastically remunerative to you
because you're a pioneer
and the point is
how many of those spots like you know
the NBA lures people who might have
studied something that would have given
them a route out of bad economic
circumstances but because the Allure of
that small number of positions is so
great it causes people not to realize
actually the chances that I'm going to
get there are so low I can't I can't do
this and so in any case the point is
look a small number of people can do
what you're doing Ayla and if they do
I'm not saying it Laurel
make civilization non-viable but you are
playing with the stuff that does run
that risk you're not the only one
playing with the only set of things that
put it at risk but this is one of the
things that puts it at risk and so in
any case
think about whether or not the people
who are reacting to you are not just
having a hissy fit but in fact are
trying to explain something that isn't
easily explained which is
when you do what you're doing it becomes
impossible for civilization to function
in any way that it has ever functioned
before right you are gambling on the
fact that some functional mode of
civilization will be compatible with
what you're doing and there's no proof
of that no civilization has ever
functioned in the way that you're
advocating and so anyway
um I think this is more than people just
you know clutching their pearls and
reaching for fainting couches this is
actually people who can't quite explain
the problem with what you're doing but
it doesn't mean there isn't one
indeed all right well I think we've
arrived
um we will be here same time next week
again next week we will not be doing a q
a but we'll be back the week after that
hopefully uh with with the time once
again uh when uh when other constraints
don't
uh don't show up on next Saturday Brit
has his his patreon meeting before a
live stream consider joining him there
and either our patreons again you can
find our wonderful Discord server and
join me on Natural Selections I'm
reprinting this upcoming week a uh an
essay that was only available in a in an
anthology that was not widely available
called
I don't know he she
can't even remember what it's called
[Music]
it's a bunch of pronouns it's it's not
widely available so I don't know what it
was called no no you don't um
yeah it was it was in this iconoclast
Anthology and it's an exploration
another exploration but the longest one
that I've done of um both both trans
identity and also of
the thing that is being called Envy um
so that's how Natural Selections this
upcoming week
and uh until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]